hey mr stark what should i do what we
discuss keep your distance web him up
okay copy that
[Music]
move captain i won't ask a second time
look i really don't want to hurt you i
wouldn't stress about it
[Music]
what the hell is that everyone's got a
gimmick now
you have a metal arm that is awesome
dude
you have the right to remain silent
[Music]
sorry cactus won't kill you but it ain't
going to tickle either
wanda i think you heard visions feelings
you locked me in my room
okay first that's an exaggeration second
i did it to protect you
hey clint hey man clearly retirement
doesn't suit you
you got tired of shooting golf well i
played 18. shot 18.
this can't seem to miss
[Music]
first time for everything made you look
multiple contusions detected yeah i
detected that too
oh god hey buddy i think you lost this
those wings carving fiber is this stuff
coming out of you that would explain the
rigidity flexibility ratio which
gotta say that's awesome i don't know if
you've been in a fight before but
there's usually not this much talk
all right sorry my bad
[Music]
guys look i'd love to keep this up but
i've only got one job here today and i
got to impress mr stark so
i'm really sorry
you couldn't have done that earlier i
hate you
you